Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P Here's a caller who says,
I don't know. David In a way, kids are
being forced to drag time storey hours.
This is a joke, by the way. Take a listen.
Speaker 9: David it's Al from Jersey and
watching the podcast today and you keep saying
the drag times, story hour and drag queens are
optional and these are optional things that
parents are choosing and anybody can choose
not to do it. And you're completely wrong.
I mean, I can understand if you were right,
the outrage would be unjustified. But the outrage
is justified because these drag queens. Story
hour. And these drag queens are mandatory, David,
because you can't opt out of living in a country
where Drag Queen story hour exists, right? Choose
to live in a town or a city or state or country
where this isn't happening. So these people
are being forced to live in a country where
drag Queen story hour is a thing that exists.
Speaker 1: Okay, now I get that this is a joke,
but there is an element of truth to the reaction,
which is even when you explain to a lot of these
anti drag show people, listen, you're if you even
have kids, right. A lot of them complaining don't
even have kids. They're worried about kids. They
have no kids. They don't actually have any clue
what's going on. But if you do have kids, you know
that they're not being forced to do any drag drag
stuff. Right. Like, do you understand that these
are events where parents bring their kids to just
don't go. They actually don't care. And they would
respond with something along the lines of, well,
the problem is it's in the environment. They
wouldn't literally, you know, like this guy
is making a joke and I get it. But they would say
it's still around. Even if I don't bring my kids,
they still hear about it or whatever the
case may be. And that's the problem and
we've got to deal with it. So the caller is
joking, but he's not really exaggerating by
that much. Today on the bonus show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where
you want to make money. Yeah. Everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Today's show almost didn't happen.
And I'm going to explain why at the top of the
bonus show, we will also talk about the latest
inflation numbers. Inflation numbers as low as
they have been since 2021. And BuzzFeed has lost
$106 million. There's a bit in the last quarter,
there is a bigger media story that is a separate
story from big tech that I want to talk about. And
it will also allow for some discussion of elements
that have affected the show to some degree.
And I think people will find it interesting. I
believe otherwise I wouldn't be talking about it.
All of those stories are on today's bonus show.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com to get
instant access you can use the coupon code 24
starts now to get a discount if you so choose.